a medida que empezamos a graficar líneas
podemos notar que hay diferencia entre
ellas verdad por ejemplo esta línea rosa
parece más pronunciada o más empinada
que la línea azul que tenemos en este
plano y lo que veremos es esta noción
que mide qué tan empinada está una recta
es decir qué tan rápido incrementa o qué
tan rápido disminuye y es una idea muy
pero muy útil en matemáticas
así que lo que queremos es asignar un
número a cada línea para poder describir
qué tan empinada está o qué tan rápido
incrementa o disminuye qué forma
razonable tendríamos para lograr esto
bueno una forma de pensarlo es ver qué
tanto incrementa una línea en la
dirección vértiz vertical por cada
incremento en la dirección horizontal
muy bien así que vamos a vamos a
escribir esto vamos a comparar el
incremento en la dirección vertical en
la dirección vertical y esto lo vamos a
dividir es una forma de compararlo con
el incremento incremento en la dirección
horizontal muy bien entonces vamos a ver
cómo es que esto nos da un número por
ejemplo parémonos en algún punto fácil
de la línea rosa por ejemplo en este
punto y si nosotros aumentamos una
unidad en la dirección horizontal
podemos ver que aún
estamos aumentamos dos unidades en la
dirección vertical verdad entonces si
nosotros ponemos eso como tenemos en
esta definición teníamos dos aumentos 22
unidades de aumento en la dirección
vertical dividido entre un incremento o
más bien una unidad de incremento en la
dirección horizontal lo cual nos da un
valor de 2 verdad ahora bien la cuestión
es que no importa donde empecemos por
ejemplo si volvemos a iniciar ahora en
este punto y digamos que ahora se nos
ocurre avanzar tres unidades a la
derecha muy bien digamos que se nos
derecha ahí tenemos tres unidades a la
derecha entonces deberíamos avanzar el
doble hacia arriba verdad es decir 1 2
3 4 5 6 unidades hacia arriba muy bien
entonces aquí avanzamos 3 unidades a la
derecha y avanzamos 6 unidades hacia
arriba si ponemos esto en términos de la
división entre los incrementos
tendríamos 6 incrementos en la dirección
vertical dividido entre 3 incrementos en
la dirección horizontal entonces si eres
bastante observador te darás cuenta que
estos dos estas dos fracciones dan el
mismo resultado
2 dividido entre 1 nos da 2 y 6 dividido
entre 3 nos da 2 verdad entonces no
importa donde empezamos ni cuántas
digamos unidades avanzamos en la
dirección horizontal eso nos debe dar
siempre lo mismo ya este número es lo
que vamos a conocer con pendiente con el
nombre de pendiente y es una noción que
los matemáticos se utilizan para medir
qué tan empinada es una recta entonces
esta noción es la se le conoce como
pendiente verdad y quizás y este es un
poco relacionado con el término quizás
en no sean aplicaciones de la vida
diaria verdad
entonces como vimos la pendiente de esta
recta la pendiente de la recta rosa oops
debería escribirlo un poco mejor la
pendiente es igual a 2 verdad y nuestra
interpretación geométrica es que vamos a
tener dos unidades de incremento en la
dirección vertical por cada una unidad
que nos movemos en la dirección
horizontal verdad y como vimos no
importa realmente donde estemos parados
por ejemplo podríamos no ser estar en
esta aumentar uno y medio y entonces
vamos a tener que subir tres unidades
verdad no importa donde nos pongamos
sobre la recta ni cuánto aumentemos en
la dirección horizontal siempre esa
proporción se va a mantener ahora bien
cuál sería la pendiente de nuestra recta
azul que íbamos y voy a reescribir lo de
otra forma típica que verán que veremos
para describir la pendiente y que de
hecho es una convención que han
introducido los matemáticos
también la pendiente la pendiente se
puede escribir como el cambio en la
dirección vertical dividido entre la
dirección que tenemos entre el cambio en
la dirección que tenemos
digamos horizontalmente verdad entonces
este símbolo este símbolo es la letra
griega delta y es la delta mayúscula
verdad ambas letras son la letra griega
delta y esto literalmente lo que
significa es cambio entonces arriba
tenemos cambio en el cambio en la
dirección de la coordenada ya que si nos
fijamos es el eje el eje digamos
vertical dividido entre el cambio el
cambio en x que es nuestra coordenada de
la dirección horizontal verdad entonces
si queremos utilizar esta esta
definición que es exactamente la misma
que teníamos arriba vamos a ver qué pasa
con la recta azul por ejemplo si nos
colocamos en no sé por ejemplo
en este punto de aquí
este punto de aquí y digamos que
aumentamos no sé dos unidades dos
unidades aquí nuestro cambio en x es dos
unidades ya la derecha vamos a tener un
cambio en de 2 también verdad tenemos un
cambio en de 2 unidades
entonces nuestra pendiente según esta
definición tendríamos que la pendiente
vamos a escribirlo la pendiente de
nuestra recta es el cambio dividido
entre el cambio en x pero el cambio en
jr resultó ser 2 y dividimos entre el
cambio en x que es también 2 y eso nos
da 1 muy bien entonces nuestra pendiente
es 1 y lo mismo hubiera sucedido si por
ejemplo avanzáramos 3 en la dirección
horizontal y si hubiéramos 3 verdad es
la misma proporción 3 entre 3 nos debe
dar 1 o bien también podría haber
ocurrido que estuviéramos en
un punto no sé digamos este punto y
avanzaremos dos a la izquierda de esos
tendríamos que nuestro delta x es menos
2 y entonces tendríamos un cambio en y
hacia abajo quiere decir que nuestro del
taller sería menos 2 verdad entonces
tenemos en nuestro camión que sería
menos 2 dividido en nuestro entre
nuestro cambio en x que también es menos
2 y menos 2 entre menos 2 vuelve a
darnos 1 que es el valor de la pendiente
que ya teníamos